hey everyone its era thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video I'm
gonna demonstrate for you how to use a
metered dose inhaler using both the open
mouth and closed mouth technique so what
is a metered dose inhaler this is an
inhaler used to deliver a set amount of
medication into the patient's lung and
the medications include like
bronchodilators like albuterol a brand
name for that is like ventolin or pro
air along with corticosteroids such as
fluticasone which is known as flovent
and patients who have respiratory
diseases like asthma COPD may be
prescribed these inhalers now these
inhalers can also be used and be ordered
as a combination where there's one
inhaler but there's two different types
of drugs in them like symbicort which
would contain a bronchodilator and a
corticosteroids so you want to keep that
in mind and always look at what your
patients going to be taking another
thing is is that you want to teach the
patient proper technique when using
these inhalers because if they don't use
them correctly what will happen is that
not a lot of the medication will get
down into their lungs it'll just stay in
their mouth and that is a big issue with
some of these medications like
corticosteroids so whenever you are
teaching the patient how to use an
inhaler try to get a spacer this is what
it looks like and it attaches onto the
inhaler and they inhale through that
which I will be demonstrating in the
next video how to use but if and then
hey if a spacer is not available you can
use the open or closed now technique and
always go by whatever the physician has
prescribed for the patient while the
patients will tell you what they've been
using and you need to make sure that
they're doing it right now why would you
want to use a spacer
well the spacer is going to be easier to
use than that
open mouth the closed mouth technique
because whenever you're using this
inhaler with those techniques you have
to simultaneously press the inhaler down
and inhale at the same time which takes
a lot of practice so if you have a
really young
patient or a patient who's older who has
issues with holding the inhaler that can
be troublesome also then hailer in the
chamber is going to allow this in a
sense lead time for them to inhale the
inhaler substance so they don't have to
press it down simultaneously and it's
going to decrease the amount of
medication that's going to be left in
the mouth which with corticosteroids we
don't want that because it can cause
mouth irritation like thrush so what
we're going to do first is we're going
to perform hand hygiene and we're going
to perform the patient's five rites
we're going to make sure that we have
the right patient the right drug the
right dose we're doing that at the right
time and the right rap and you always
want to look at what you're giving
because whenever you're doing these
inhalers or some things you want to keep
in mind okay say you were going to be
giving a bronchodilator inhaler and a
corticosteroid inhaler so you have two
inhalers it's very important you know
which one you need to give first the
first one you want to give is the
bronchodilator because it's going to
open up those lungs and die like that
then you need to wait five minutes and
then administer the corticosteroid
because then the corticosteroid can get
in there and do it straw by decreasing
the inflammation now say you were giving
two puffs of a bronchodilator and that
was it or two puffs of the
corticosteroids and that was if you
would first do a puff of the
bronchodilator and say they need another
Ronco dilator puff you would wait one
minute and then give the other ones so
if you're giving the same medication
just two different doses you're gonna
wait one minute but if you were going to
give a bronchodilator then a
corticosteroid you would wait five
minutes because we need five minutes for
the bronchodilator to do its job and
then another thing you need to remember
is that after the patient uses then
hailer after doing a corticosteroid they
need to rinse they need to gargle and
rinse their mouth with water and then
spit that water out because the
corticosteroid whenever he comes into
contact with those mucous membranes and
the mouth it can cause thrush so it's
very important you get your patient to
do that next what you want to do is you
want to prime then hailer so you're
going to prime the inhaler if it's the
first time you're ever using that if the
patient hasn't use it in a week or more
has dropped it or recently cleaned it so
before you do that just make sure that
your inhaler is in de it's not expired
so to do that what you're going to do is
you're just going to gently pop this
canister off and it will tell you the
expiration date this is 2020 so we're in
date and the dose that we're using in
this inhaler the reason here is a demo
dose it's a teaching dose that doesn't
like contain medication also never
administer medications to a patient if
you don't have proper credentials or if
you've not been trained and always
follow your Hospital protocols
so another thing whenever you're going
to go priming you want to check
expiration date but you also want to
make sure that there's enough doses in
this inhaler because they only contain
so many puffs so a lot of inhalers have
a counter on them and it'll tell you how
many's last like 2010 however many so
look there to make sure you have enough
and if it doesn't say it like this one
doesn't the box will tell you how many
sprays are in each inhaler and this one
has 200 sprays so you'll need to pay
attention to how many sprays the
patient's doing a day and calculate that
out for instance say that the patient is
doing two puffs twice a day so how many
puffs is admin today four and there's
only 200 puffs in this box how many days
is this inhaler going to last if they do
it every day just 50 days so you want to
keep track of that now two problem
inhaler what we're going to do is we're
going to remove the cap and then just
hold with your thumb at the bottom and
your two fingers at the top and gently
give it a shake and depending on the
manufacturer is how many sprays you're
gonna spray to prime it because each and
hailers difference always read the
instructions with this one it's four so
what we're going to do is just do four
sprays now that our inhaler is prime let
me demonstrate for you the open mouth
technique I'm going to tell you about it
and then I will show you how to do it or
so what you're gonna do is you're gonna
have your patient set up and you're
gonna have them hold the inhaler in
between their thumb and their two
fingers and give it a good shake for
about eight to ten seconds just to mix
up that medication and really good then
they're going to measure out two fingers
with between their mouth and then hailer
and make sure that inhaler is pointed at
their mouth and what they want to do is
they want to breathe in and then breathe
out through their mouth until they no
longer can and then after that
simultaneously they want to hit the
inhaler down and breathe in slowly
through the mouth of the stuff that's
coming out of the inhaler and then
they'll want to hold their breath for 10
to 12 seconds and breathe out slowly if
they need another puff of that same
medication they can do it in one minute
so let me show you how to do that
then after that retype the inhaler and
if it was a corticosteroid be sure to
gargle and rinse the mouth with water
and spit and perform hand hygiene and
document now let me demonstrate the
closed mouth technique so what you want
to do is hold inhaler in between the
thumb and the fingers and give it a good
shake for about eight to ten seconds to
get the medication mix well and you'll
have the patient take a breath in and
then out through their mouth until they
can no longer exhale and then put the
mouthpiece of the inhaler in between the
tea keeping the tongue flat on the lips
sealed around it and they will
simultaneously hit then hellar button
and breathe in until they no longer can
breathe in and then hold it for about
ten seconds and then exhale slowly and
that will look something like this
and after that recap inhaler and again
if they were using a corticosteroid have
the patient gargle and rinse the mouth
and spit with water and perform hand
hygiene and document and if they needed
to use the same medication again how
when would they do it they would do it
in a minute but if they were going to be
using say this was a bronchodilator and
they needed to use the corticosteroid
how long would they wait five minutes
okay so that wraps up this video on how
to use a metered dose inhaler using the
open and closed mouth technique thank
you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos